Frau geilwitz die wir haben uns heute
farblich ein bisschen abgestimmt ne wird
sehr harmonische Sendung da bin ich mir
sicher W äh wie geht es Ihnen als
bundesbauministerin gerade jetzt so an
Weihnachten äh wenn es äh so viele
Menschen gibt die in 2024 kein
bezahlbares Dach überm Kopf haben das
ist etwas was natürlich für mich nicht
schön ist sie haben es ja gesagt dass
ausgerechnet mit der aus meiner Sicht
ganz wichtigen Neugründung des
Bauministeriums zeitgleich eine große
Krise am Bauch kam
aber gleichzeitig ist es natürlich
wichtig dass das nicht mein Problem ist
sondern das Problem von vielen den es
wirklich jetzt schwer fällt eine neue
bezahlbare Wohnung zu finden und er ist
auch ihr Problem ne politisch sie können
das ändern also oder Sie müssen es
ändern damit die kein Problem haben mein
täglicher Job und das Problem ist leider
jetzt nicht aufgetaucht vor kurzem
sondern das ist das Resultat von einer
fehlenden Prioritätensetzung man hat
sich vor 20 Jahren ziemlich getäuscht
bei der Frage wie viel deutsche werden
wir wohl bal mal sein man hat gesagt
Deutschland ist fertig gebaut wir
brauchen gar keinen neuen Wohnraum und
man hat z.B dann das Bauministerium
aufgelöst und über zwei Jahrzehnte gab
es niemanden am Kabinettstisch der
darauf Fokus gesetzt hat wer war der
letzte war Haus Seehofer ne genau das
war im Prinzip mein Amtsvorgänger aber
das war ein kleines ein kleiner Bereich
am Innenministerium dran was sozusagen
auch die nicht vorhandene Priorität der
Vorgängerregierung in dem zusammen habe
ich eine eine Frage die mich sehr
interessiert ich habe irgendwo gelesen
mm dass Horst Seehofer immer damit
hausieren gegangen ist dass er angeblich
300.000 Wohnungen pro Jahr geschafft hat
375 000 glaube ich sogar ne so nein also
375 000 war das Ziel das war das Ziel
das war das Ziel und knapp unter 300 000
und ich könnte jetzt mir einen ganz
billigen Scherz erlauben und sagen im
letzten Jahr haben wir sogar ein
bisschen mehr gebaut als Frost Seehofer
im Jahr davor aber das wäre wirklich
unfair weil die Zusammenhänge sind so
kompliziert mit me das jetzt weder dem
einen Minister noch dem anderen in aus
Butterbrot spielen mir geht mir geht's
darum sozusagen mal klar zumachen wie
dann auch so getrixt wird und man sagt
na läuft doch und dann stehen wir aber
plötzlich vorm riesenschlamassel stimmt
es dass Horst Seehofer in diese 300.000
Wohnungen auch die Rohbauten einfach
vorsichtshalber schon mal mit
eingerechnet hat so nach der Motto Dach
ist drauf reicht nein also das in
Deutschland haben wir da eine
ordentliche Statistik die warau
fertigstellungsstatistik die wird immer
im Jahr danach im Mai veröffentlicht
ja jren versucht hat ein Handwerker zu
kriegen wird ja festgestellt haben er
hat keinen bekommen die Baupreise sind
extrem nach oben gegangen also wir haben
unterschiedliche Probleme und die Lösung
das ist jetzt auch eine bittere
Nachricht die dauert natürlich auch
einige Jahre und bevor wir gleich zu der
ganzen politischen Dimension kommen noch
mal versuchen klar zumachen wie ernst
man das Thema auch lange genommen hat
als sie angefangen haben in ihrem
Ministerium wie muss man sich das
vorstellen wie wie viele Leute wie viele
Computer wie waren sie ausgerüstet wie
fing das an also das Bauministerium die
Bauabteilung sitzt in einem
wunderschönen ehrwürdigen Gebäude mit
einem patanosta und da wird auch noch
der Hauch der 50er Jahre und das ist ja
nicht das Problem dass das
Bauministerium altes Gebäude hat sondern
dass wir tatsächlich in den letzten
Jahrzehnten viele Chancen verpasst haben
um überhaupt preiswert wieder zu bauen
das heißt der komplette
digitalisierungsbereich war nicht
vorangetrieben wir haben nicht intensiv
mit den Ländern darüber gesprochen was
man in den Bauordnung anpassen muss und
natürlich haben wir über Jahrzehnte
leider den sozialen Wohnungsbau
vernachlässigt weil es ja nicht nur die
Frage was wird gebaut weil viele Leute
können sich ein Neubau für 18 € nicht
leisten und wir haben eine
wohngeldreform gemacht das heißt wir
zahlen jetzt 5 Milliarden damit Menschen
sich ihre Wohnung noch leisten können
über über die den den großen politischen
Zusammenhang reden wir gleich ich find
nur mal Politik ist ja auch Handwerk wie
viele Mitarbeiter hatten sie als sie so
anfingen wie ging das Los sie als
bauministerin die erste seit langer Zeit
also am Anfang wenn man so eine neue
Behörde hat ich hatte nur die zwei
Fachabteilung das heißt es gab sozusagen
weder ein Pressesprecher noch ein
Büroleiter noch irgendwas das mussten
wir alles aufbauen so haben sie
angefangen genau also am ersten Tag habe
ich mir tatsächlich auch mein Kaffee
selber mitgebracht weil da war keiner
mehr aber das interessiert glaub ich
auch nichtklich zwei Fachabteilungen wie
groß wie viele sind das na ja das waren
vielleicht so 200 Leute jetzt sind wir
über
500 das ist alles ne also man muss ja
wissen das Bauministerium setzt die
gesetzlichen Regelungen wir bauen die
400.000 Wohnungen nicht selber das wäre
da dann biss ein bisschen wenig ja ja
ich ich also sie verstehen mein
Erstaunen ne also mit dem Wissen geht
jemand wie Olaf Scholz in den Wahlkampf
und sagt und war ein wichtiges ein ganz
zentrales Versprechen in diesem
Wahlkampf 400.000 neuewohnungen pro Jahr
und dann höre ich von ihnen dass sie
sich selber den Kaffee mitbringen und
dass sie gerade mal zwei te ilungen
haben und das ist alles so sehr
hemsärmlich also ich sage mal wie passt
das zusammen dieses große Versprechen
und dann diese Professionalität auf der
anderen Seite ja weil die Frage wie viel
Wohnung in Deutschland hergestellt
werden ganz entscheidend davon abhängen
z.B wie die Hypothekenzinsen sind und
nicht ob Kara gewitz eine besonders
schöne Kaffeemaschine hat ne das ist
schon klar aber sie sie symbolisiert was
an dem Punkt nein also ganz ehrlich das
war ja als dieses Versprechen gemacht
wurde war das ja nicht eine Idee von
Olaf Scholz weil ja nach 400000 das ist
immer eine schön klingende Zahl sondern
das war der damals tatsächlich
errechnete Bedarf der jetzige Bedarf ist
deutlich höher natürlich ist er noch
höher weil wir z. ja also sie berichten
ja sehr intensiv über die Ukraine und
sie wissen natürlich dass Menschen aus
der Ukraine nach Deutschland gekommen
sind die konnten logischerweise in den
damals errechneten Bedarf gar nicht drin
sein und dem zufolge hat man gesagt der
damals berechnete Bedarf waren die
400.000 wir kamen von einer
Fertigstellung von 300
das war Steigerung die ambitioniert aber
machbar war zuer Phase wo wir extrem
niedrige Zinsen hatten und der
Baubereich ist derjenige der am
schnellsten auf zinssteigung reagiert
deswegen ist mein Ziel jetzt erstmal
dass wir stabil durch diese Phase kommen
wo wir sehr große Probleme im Baubereich
haben damit wir keine Kapazitäten
abbauen die wir dringend
brauchen ich schau mal zu Herrn Bern
gerade der sich mit mit Städteplanung
Entwicklung so viel beschäftigt meine
was sie sagen wie hoch ist der Bedarf
tatsächlich den wir wirklich haben um
nur mal die Zahlen sozusagen der
Gegenwart zu zu referieren wir haben
2022 knapp 300.000 Wohnungen gebaut
glaube ich 221 war es ähnlich wir haben
2020 sogar mal knapp über 300.000
geschafft wir werden in diesem Jahr
gerade mal
250.000 schaffen wie viel schaffen wir
nächstes Jahr wahrscheinlich weniger da
Wohnung bauen einen langen Vorlauf hat
und wohn die jetzt Wohnung jetzt fertig
gestellt werden sind ja schon vor ein
zwei Jahren geplant worden ne also
geplant worden in der Zeit dass die
Bedingung noch nicht ganz so schwierig
wir brauchen viel mehr werden aber
ungefähr bei 200 000 rauskommen oder was
würden Sie sagen das kann ich nicht
prophezeien ich habe keine Glaskugel und
das hat Frau geiit in ihr Ministerium
viel besser im Blick als ich aber was
ich wichtig finde ist jetzt nicht nur
auf die baufertigstellungszahlen zu
gucken sondern auch zu gucken was gebaut
wird und was bezahlbar gebaut wird und
da ist auch glaube ich ein Blick in die
Statistik noch mal interessant die Pläne
der bundesre Regierung berichtigen sie
mich waren eigentlich 400.000 Wohnungen
pro Jahr davon 100.000 Sozialwohnung
letztes Jahr waren es 285 000 Wohnungen
glaube ich die neu gebaut worden sind
insgesamt aber nur 25 000 Sozialwohnung
gleichzeitig sind 36 000 Wohnungen aus
der Bindung gefallen wir haben 1 Million
Sozialwohnung noch wir hatten mal 4
Millionen und wir haben war geht sehr
schnell mit den vielen aktuell eine
Millionen Sozialwohnungen in den 1980er
Jahren hatte die Bundesrepublik noch
ungefähr 4 Millionen Sozialwohnungen die
Sozialwohnung sind runter auf eine
Million gleichzeitig haben wir 11
Millionen Leute die ein Anspruch hätten
auf eine Sozialwohnung das heiß wir
haben eine Million versus 11 Millionen
genau das heißt wir können nicht mal
jedem zehnten der eigentlich eine
Sozialwohnung kriegen könnte eine
Sozialwohnung bieten und da finde ich
aber wichtig eben diesen Niedergang von
4 Millionen wenn wir die 4 Millionen
sozialbung noch hätten dann könnten sie
in vielm Punkt viel beruhigter in die
Weihnachten schauen ne nicht nur ich und
deswegen finde ich eigentlich wir müssen
darüber reden warum sind wir von 4
Millionen auf Milon Sozialwohnung
rtergegangen und das hat eben sehr viel
damit zu tun wie wir in Deutschland
sozialen Wohnungsbau fördern das hat ein
österreichischer wohnungsforscher mal
als Investitionsförderung mit sozialer
Zwischennutzung bezeichnet ja also der
Staat gibt einem Investor Geld dafür
dass er Wohnung baut im Gegenzug
verpflichtet sich der Investor für 30 40
Jahre preiswerte mieten anzubieten wenn
die ausgelaufen sind ist der Effekt Weg
die Wohnung verpuffen ne können wieder
am Markt zu Markt mieten angeboten
werden das ist einfach Modell wo wir
sehen das ist nicht nachhaltig und wenn
man nicht die die ganze Zeit immer
wieder Geld nachschießt geht man
automatisch den Berg runter und das ist
das was in letzten 30 Jahren sozusagen
viele Regierungen falsch gemacht haben
daher finde ich es nicht zu kurz
gegriffen wenn immer nur auf die
aktuellen baufertigstellungszahlen guckt
sondern ich denke wir müssen wirklich
gucken in welchem System wir feststecken
und wo wir ein Systemwechsel Hink
kriegen gibt es dieses bessere System in
anderen Ländern wo wo es gibt sehr viele
unterschiedliche Systeme wie sozialer
Wohnungsbau betrieben wird muss man
sagen vielen Ländern ist sozialer
Wohnungsbau quasi öffentlicher
Wohnungsbau das sind Wohnungen die
werden gebaut sie gehören dann dem Staat
ja in England heißt z.B das was h social
housing nennen wird dort landläuf immer
als Council housing bezeichnet weil es
einfach den Bezirk gehört in Schweden
ist es eine ganz ähnliche Sache in der
Schweiz setzt man viel stärker auf
Genossenschaften ich glaube in Zürich
sind Drittel des Wohnungsbestandes
gehört Genossenschaften die seit 100
Jahren da billige Wohnung anbieten also
es gibt sehr viele Beispiele im Ausland
aus denen man ganz viel lernen kann ja
ja Wien ist auch eine Stadt die immer
wieder genannt werd ne absolut die
Wiener haben den sogenannten
gemeindewohnungsbau damit haben sie den
19 20er Jahren schon angefangen
und im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen
europäischen Ländern sind sie dabei
geblieben sie haben nichts verkauft sie
sind in dem System geblieben das
generiert sozusagen sich aus sich selber
zum großen Teil also die Erträge die
dort ähm aus den Mieten kommen werden
wieder
reininvestiert und dadurch habe ich in
Wien sehr also ich glaube fast die
Hälfte der Wiener Wohnung sind entweder
Gemeindewohnung oder im
gemeinwohlorientierten Sektor und
dadurch ist also fast die Hälfte des
gesamten Bestandes einfach sehr gut
bezahlbar sehr preiswert und das merkt
man auch wenn man nach Wien fährt man
hat eigentlich fast über alle eine
ziemlich gute soziale Mischung man hat
viel weniger Segregation also so
sozialräumliche Spaltung zwischen
verschiedenen Gruppen und Schichten als
man das bei uns in Großstädten
inzwischen gewohnt ist so interessante
Gemeindebau heißt das in Wien TS es gibt
dieses kennen kennen Sie vielleicht noch
diesen großartigen Song von Wolfgang
Ambrus die Blume aus dem Gemeindebau
besingt ja genau genau das eine sehr
schöne junge Frau aus dem
Gemeindebau der Unternehmer sitzt bei
uns den sie gerade ansprechen her
Goldbeck ist das für jemanden wie
sie hab sie gerade vorgestellt dass
jemand der serielles wohnen nach vorne
bringt ist sozialer Wohnungsbau ist das
für Sie
interessant ja unbedingt also wir sind
seit 5 Jahren ungefähr in dem
wohnungsbaubereich wir kommen eigentlich
aus dem industriellen und gewerblichen
Bereich aber soziales heiß haben
gewerbeebiete sozusagen hochgezogen
Logistikhallen Produktionshallen Schulen
Büros Parkhäuser das ist so da kommen
wir her und jetzt sind wir bei wohnen
gelandet eben weil wir denken dass wir
mit unserem seriellen
produktorientierten Ansatz hier eine
Lösung bieten können okay das heißt
warum ist das für Sie interessant
sozialer Wohnungsbau machen ja viele
nicht das ist für uns ob er jetzt als
sozial tituliert ist oder eben
entsprechend privat kostengünstig
errichtet ist eigentlich hinlänglich
egal also hauptsächlich geht es darum
schnell günstig gute Wohnungen zu
produzieren warum passiert das so wenig
Herr Blätter warum funktioniert das
nicht mehr in Deutschland wie es Herr
Bern gerade beschrieben hat also es ist
natürlich eine sehr komplizierte und
mehrschichtige Frage also Frau Geiwitz
eben das Gesicht der Wohnungskrise das
ist insofern natürlich ungerecht weil
Frau Geiwitz nur auf einen ganz kleinen
Teil der Regelung die uns behindern
Einfluss hat das Problem der Regierung
ist dass sie durch das Versprechen dass
sie gemacht hat mit den 400.000
Wohnungen natürlich eine
Lösungskompetenz suggeriert die sie nur
bedingt hat es hat sehr
unterschiedlicheben ist eine schöne
Formulierung für man sollte nicht Dinge
versprechen die man nicht halten kann
oder ja ich glaube wir sind in ich würde
vielleicht das kurz noch beantworten und
dann Ihre Frage ich ich glaube wir sind
momentan schon in einer Situation in der
wir natürlich sehen dass die Menschen
wohnen heute im Durchschnitt auf knapp
50 me 1991 wundten sie noch auf 35
ungefähr das heißt die Ansprüche sind
gach die Ansprüche sind gestiegen und
das Problem dass die Regierung nun hat
ist dass sie den Leuten in jeder Rede
erzählt seit Olaf Scholz regiert es wird
sich nichts ändern in allen Krisen hat
jetzt beim Haushaltsstreit wieder eine
Rede gehalten in der er gesagt hat
obwohl wir wissen dass das Geld hinten
und vorne fehlt es wird sich nichts
ändern und dieser zumutungsentzug dieses
regieren durch
zumutungsentzug trifft jetzt ein Volk
eine Gesellschaft ein
landungsentzug gewöhnt seit vielen
Jahren morgen ist mehr da als gestern
und das hat immer funktioniert also
Wirtschaftswachstum hat auch eine sozial
befriedende Wirkung und was wir jetzt
beim Wohnen sehen ist dass wir als Land
als Bevölkerung es gewöhnt sind
plötzlich in Städten auf größeren
Flächen zu wohnen und gleichzeitig sind
wir in einem Krieg die ukreine ist
angegriffen worden wir haben gestiegene
Energiekosten wir werden als Land
zumindest vorübergehend ärmer und wir
haben gleichzeitig da kann Frau geibit
auch überhaupt nichts für konkurrierende
Interessen in der Regierung da wür ich
die Regierung sogar nicht mal immer für
verhauen weil die spiegelt ja auch das
Land Land die wählerschaftt manche
wollen mehr für Klima tun andere mehr
für bauen das heißt man muss die
Ressourcen priorisieren was man Olaf
Scholz aber vorwerfen kann ist und ich
halte das wirklich für ein Problem dass
den Leuten zu sagen alles wird gut
nichts wird sich ändern niemand wird
sich verkleinern müssen das führt zu
einem gesellschaftlichen Klima in dem
die Leute sich nicht bewegen und jetzt
komme ich zu Ihrer Frage was muss man
tun es sind wirklich sehr viele Ebenen
und wenn ich noch einen Punkt machen
darf weil ich glaube der wird immer
unterschätzt wir gucken auf die
Bundesregierung wir gucken auf die
Industrie ein ganz wichtiger Punkt sind
die Kommunen und in den Kommunen gibt es
sehr sehr viele Menschen die ihr
Eigentum verteidigen indem sie
verhindern dass neu gebaut wird das gibt
wenn ich den Punkt Gicht muss ich kurz
ausholen aber ich glaub es ist wirklich
wichtig das sicher als Forschung es gibt
in Amerika das Phänomen des exclusionary
zonings das bedeutet also wörtlich
übersetzt ausschließende Zonenbildung im
Kern beschreibt sich dahinter das
Phänomen das reiche Menschen zugespitzt
ihre Gegenden verteidigen gegen
Neubauten weil dann der Wert Ihres
eigenen Heims sinkt durch neuen Wohnraum
wie tun sie das es gibt baurechtliche
Regelungen auf die kann man lokal
Einfluss nehmen sie dürfen brauchen
Tiefgaragen sie dürfen auf 1000 madr nur
100 madr Grund bebauen sie verknappen
den Wohnraum durch das Baurecht das
passiert auch in Deutschland in
Deutschland ist das eine kommunale
Aufgabe wie sie Bebauungspläne bestimmen
das passiert in kommunalen Parlamenten
normalerweise wenn jemand in Hamburg
Eimsbüttel in einer 100 m langen
Schlange steht um eine Wohnung zu
besichtigen denkt er natürlich nicht
drüber nach ich stehe hier in der
Schlange weil in irgendeinem reichen
Stadtteil nicht gebaut wird wo wir das
aber gesehen haben war 2015 2015 und in
den Folgejahren konnte man plötzlich
messen wie viele Flüchtlinge übernimmt
welcher Stadtteil wo werden
Flüchtlingsheime gebaut das wurde
plötzlich öffentlich ausgetragen und wir
hatten hier in Hamburg einen Fall in
Rissen relativ vermögender Stadtteil in
dem schon vorher verhindert wurde
Wohnungsbau in einer bestimmten Gegend
und dann wurden Flüchtlingsheime
verhindert das waren viel zu viele
Flüchtlinge für diese Gegend das war
richtig also war begründeter Widerstand
aber das Ergebnis dieses Widerstandes
war dass die Flüchtlingsheime die
Initiative hat Bürger für Integration
gesagt also die meinten halt integration
bedeutet das machen dann andere
Stadtteile es führte nämlich dazu dass
ein erheblicher Teil der
integrationslast in Gegenden kam in
denen heute schon die Schulen viele
Kinder integrieren müssen und was hat
das mit dem Bauen zu tun es ist so dass
momentan wenn Sie beispielsweise klagen
wollen gegen einen Neubau in ihrer
Gegend ma mit dem
gebietserhaltungsanspruch das können Sie
als Eigentümer tun wenn sie im reinen
Wohngebiet wohnen dann wollen Sie
verhindern dass dann soziale Nutzung wie
ein Flüchtlingsheim hinkommt in der
flüchtlingskrise haben wir das gesehen
dass das Verwaltungsrecht in Anschlag
gebracht wurde um diese Lasten
loszuwererden und das ist das gute Recht
von Menschen sich gegen den Staat zu
wehren Gesetze durchzusetzen aber diese
Planungen beginnen schon früher wer sind
die Menschen die Einfluss nehmen auf
Bebauungspläne das sind Leute die wählen
wir wissen in reichen Stadtteilen wird
mehr gewählt als in anderen das sind
Leute die Anwälte in die Ausschüsse
schicken das sind Leute die sich
engagieren die sich auskennen die sich
auskennen und was müssten wir eigentlich
verändern neben den sehr sehr sehr
vielen Dingen die wir verändern müssen
auf Bundesebene auf anderen Ebenen wir
müssen auch verstehen dass es unser
aller Aufgabe ist in den Kommunen die
stillen Helden das sind die Leute die in
den Kommunalparlamenten arbeiten und die
dafür sorgen dass gemeinwohlorientiertes
bauen gemacht wird nicht im Interesse
derjenigen die da bezahlen können das
werden immer weniger die
Kommunalpolitiker sind diese Helden die
das machen wenn wir nun aber einen
Kanzler haben der den Leuten sagt es
wird sich nichts ändern wir hier
schaffen diese 400.000 Wohnungen und wir
haben einen Krieg aber es ist alles
nicht schlimm nichts wird sich verändern
dann werden wir in diesem Land keine
Situation erzeugen in der die Leute
sehen wir werden ärmer zumindest
kurzfristig und wir müssen was tun und
das würde ich dem Kanzler ankreiten bei
der Energiewende von einem
Wirtschaftswunder zu reden wo wir
momentan sehen es wird teurer wir werden
keine 50er Jahre Wachstumsraten haben
auf absehbare Zeit was er gemacht hat ne
und ich was er gemacht hat und ich
glaube eine erwachsenenansprache der
Bevölkerung würden die Leute ihm auch
verzeihen Sie fänden das vielleicht
sogar gut habek hat das mal versucht zu
Beginn des Krieges als er gesagt hat wir
werden alle ärmer und es hat ihm nicht
geschadet und ich glaube dass wir diesen
Fehler machen dass wir momentan eine
eine Regierung des zumutungsentzugs
haben und diese 400.000 Wohnungen sind
nur ein Ausdruck dieser Politik wow Frau
gewitz würden sie auch so sehen also das
Wort zumutungs Zug nehme ich mir von
dieser Sendung mit in so eine kleine
Schachtel werde das Robert habbeck
schenken und heizgesetz draufschreiben
also ich glaube wenn eine
Bundesregierung gesagt hat wir müssen in
Zukunft unsere Häuser anders beheizen
und das muss jeden angehen und umtreiben
dann war es glaube ich Robert habbeck
und Klara gewitz mit dem heizungsgesetz
sie das große Glück dass der ganze Ärger
mit ihm nach Hause ging das ist der
Punkt und wir wissen auch wie es ihm
damit ergangen ist ne also das ist ja
sie hatten ja jetzt von dieser
Bundesregierung gesprochen und das von
schon sehr konkret von ihrem Kanzler
gesprochen den Mann den sie so gut
kennen wie wenige andere Kön andere
beispieleitunggesetz aber sie haben ja
einen Punkt den ich sehr richtig finde
nämlich die Frage wo kann Deutschland
was gebaut werden und wie viel konflikte
müssen dann auch Menschen tatsächlich
Kön das ein and kurz ab wür gerne noch
einmal bei dies am Ende anfangen
sozusagen die die politische Frage ist
das hat hat Herr pletter ein Punkt wenn
er sagt wir muten den Leuten unang nehme
Wahrheiten nicht zu gibt ja dann auch so
die Slogans dazu es ist ja also
politikmketing you will never walk alone
und solche Dinge ich ich ich weiß nicht
also Wums doppelwums basukas wurden
rausgeholt und so weiter das ist ja so
eine so eine Comic so eine gagaprache
zum Teil manch auch denke hat der
Bundespräsident der Altpräsident gaug
dann doch recht wenn er sagt wir reden
mit den Bürgern wie mit kleinen Kindern
also zum einen finde ich es gar nicht
schlimm wenn Politik sich bemüht
verständlich zu sein auf der and
Seite aus meinem Bereich heißt z.B dass
wir die größte Reform des Wohngeldes in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
gemacht haben und wir dieses Jahr
alleine 5 Milliarden dafür zahlen dass
Menschen ihre Miete bezahlen können und
zwar kalt und warmmete und dass wir und
das ist richtig was Sie gesagt haben wir
haben über Jahrzehnte zu wenig in
sozialen Wohnungsbau investiert dass wir
zum einen das wieder tun aber auch an
der Gemeinnützigkeit arbeiten und eine
genossenschaftsfinanzierung haben und
das andere ist wenn man sich anguckt wie
lange wir darüber bestestritten haben
auch große Stromtrassen durch die
Republik zu ziehen die einfach für die
energiwende notwendig sind wie lange wir
darüber geredet haben dass jedes
Bundesland und nicht nur Brandenburg und
Sachsen Anhalt Windräder braucht und
dass wir jetzt verbindliche Ziele haben
für jedes Bundesland und vor Ort wird
dann die Zumutung da sein dass man
tatsächlich auch in Hessen in Bayern in
Baden-Württemberg Windräder aufstellt
und sieht also das sind alles Sachen die
sind natürlich konfliktiv und da werden
auch noch eine ganze Menge auf uns
zukommen
sie weichen ein bisschen der Antwort aus
ne also die harte Ansage die die kommt
vom Kanzler nicht will never walk alone
ist ist genau das andere wir werden kein
zurücklassen werden kein allein lassen
ihr müsst euch auf nichts einstellen
aber ehrlich gesagt finde ich ist das
doch die Aufgabe einer Regierung dass
man sagt bei allen unverschuldeten
großen Lebensrisiken steht die
Gemeinschaft zu dir aber gleichzeitig
haben wir anderes andere Aussage aber es
heißt TRD dem die Gemeinschaft steht zu
dir ist völlig richtig aber sie steht
nicht zu jedem und es heißt nicht dass
jeder alles bekommt was er will na vor
allen Dingen es es es kontrastiert ja
sehr hart mit dem Gefühl dass Herr Bernt
beschreibt wenn er sagt ich hab die
Wohnungskrise ist in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft angekommen das heißt die
Leute haben doch dann ein störgefühl die
die hören einen Kanzler der dann so
redet und sagt machen wir schon und
haben aber seltsamerweise das Gefühl
irgendwie scheint das aber nicht zu
stimmen weil ich habe echt ein Thema mit
also Sie haben ja gesagt letztes Jahr
z.B wurden relativ wenig Sozialwohnungen
fertig und jetzt kann man sagen Olaf
Scholz hat doch gesagt es sollen 100.000
Sozialwohnungen pro Jahr gebaut werden
aber ich sag noch mal der Baubereich ist
etwas wo wir die strukturellen und
finanziellen Voraussetzungen schaffen
müssen Sozialwohnungen die letztes Jahr
fertig geworden sind die sind
wahrscheinlich vier Jahre vorher geplant
worden das heißt es ist jetzt nicht so
dass ich die 18 Milliarden die ich habe
für den sozialen wohnungsbraau nehme wie
so Art fehenstaub über die felderstue
und dann sind da auf einmal
Sozialwohnung das heißt das sind
natürlich Maßnahmen die verzögert
eintreten werden aber wir haben z.B für
den Bereich des serjellen Wohnungsbaus
als ich angefangen habe vor zwei Jahren
darüber zu sprechen wir haben uns da
auch so ausgetauscht da haben
Journalisten gesagt wie das sieht doch
dann aus wie ein vladivor Stock das ist
doch hässlich und wir wollen sowas nicht
und heutzutage ist das eine der großen
von fast allen akzeptierten
Möglichkeiten überhaupt die
wir Herr Bern sie wollten gerade zum zum
Thema Kommunikation störgefühl was setzt
sich da fest im kollektiven bewussein
also ich glaube dass ein störgefühl gibt
dass
die sozialen Bewegung reden immer von
mietenwahnsinn ja und ich glaube die
dieses Gefühl dass da was wahnsinniges
gerade stattfindet das was nicht stimmt
das ist weit verbreitet auf dem Weg zur
Sendung hier haben mich immer wieder
Leute gefragt was machst du denn bei
Stefan bei Markus lzigung Stefan LZ ist
ein Freund von mir heißt der so der
heißt wirklich Stefan l Wissenschaftler
an der Viadrina Universität in Frankfurt
oder Entschuldigung alles gut aber da
ich gleich noch Schleichwerbung gemacht
für ein
Kollegen also dieses Gefühl hier
passiert was es stimmt nicht mehr dass
es weit verbreitet quasi alle Leute die
gehört haben wir reden heute über mieten
wohnen bauen haben gesagt ja es ist der
Wahnsinn ja hier stimmt was nicht aber
ich frage mich wenn sie jetzt gefordert
haben dass der Kanzler sozusagen eine
Ansage machen soll da werde ich immer so
ein bisschen Mist drauf weil ich frage
mich welche Ansage ist das dann genau ja
ja und ich komme noch mal zurück auf
dies die Ansage passiert ja vorher die
Ansage ist ich verspreche euch im
Wahlkampf 400.000 Wohnungen jedes Jahr
das ist die ansageit plus na aber ist
die anage na ja aber ich ich komme noch
mal zurück auf diese
sozialwohnungszahlen ja also wenn wir 4
Millionen Mal hatten jetzt eine
Millionen haben pro Jahr
m 25 000 bauen jetzt müsste ich direkt
mal rechnen wie lange wir bräuchten um
auf den Stand von 1980 zurückzukommen ne
also das sind dann 100.000 in 4 Jahren
ähm ja dann werden wir bei 3 Millionen
in wie viel 120 Jahren ne was soll dann
da die Ansage sein die der Kanzler
machen kann wir schaffen das in meiner
letlaturperiode auf keinen Fall ja von
daher denke ich eigentlich müsste man
dann wirklich anfangen über politische
Konflikte zu reden also wer müsste wie
viel Geld in die Hand nehmen wer darf
dafür welche Gewinne
einstreichen wer hat welche
verantwortungm
und da ist es natürlich enorm ungleich
verteilt äh so sowohl unter den Bürgern
als auch in der Wirtschaft und als auch
in der Politik dann reden wir nicht nur
darüber ich verspreche was sondern ich
trte für bestimmte Weichenstellungen ein
und da ist mein Gefühl dass wir viel zu
lange auf dem pfah in der weiche die wir
eingestellt haben seit Jahrzehnten
einfach so versuchen weiterzumachen
obwohl sich die Umgebung total geändert
hat